[Applause]  hi daniel how are you  oh i'm living with animals aunt cherry  heads up don't drink the o.j  good morning henry hey girl  i figured you needed a hug  you can stop hugging i'm fine just a few  more seconds  how do you always know because we've  been friends since we were seven  and you text me last night at 3 a.m and  said i need a hug and a box of wine  i had a tough day and accidentally  watched the notebook three times  girl you need a date thank you  hey can you come by fenster hall and  take some pics of the kids for the  foster care website  yeah of course there's a new girl there  she reminds me of you she is cute but a  pain in the butt  ah that's so sweet hey guys  what was the 80s like  you